everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're gonna be going
over the england gambit trap if you're
not familiar with the england game it
starts out with pawn to d4 pawn to e5
from black not something i would like to
play as black but i do think it's
important especially if you play d4 a
lot to know what to do if your opponent
play something off the wall like pawn to
e5 you're gonna try something like black
i'd recommend the budapest defense you
have Knight to f6 then if you see pawn
c4 which is a pretty common push forward
if I've like you have a better game but
this is the England game but there'll be
another video on the English game if you
just want to try this out as black or if
you want to see other variations as a
whole but there's a specific variation
in the trap that you may see quite a bit
of want to make sure everyone is
familiar with this so after the pawn
takes here on e5 Knight to c6 attacking
of this pawn Knight to f3 just a simple
development move from white here
defending this pawn same move that I
would be playing is white I think it's
the correct move Queen to e7 this is
putting two attackers on this pawn in
the center of the board Bishop to f4
getting more material involved also
another defender on this pawn on e5 and
then Queen to b4 this attacks the bishop
it's no longer attacking the pawn so I
don't have to worry about the bishop
defending that but it is Czech so white
has to worry about that Bishop coming
back here to d2 now Queen takes on b2
and this is really the critical point in
the trap that everyone needs to be aware
of up into this point why it's played
correctly but the problem is many times
white can get in this position and think
that the move Bishop to c3 is really the
best play because if you kind of look at
it okay the Queen is attacking the rook
here on a1 okay well the best way to
defend that is to play Bishop to c3
maybe because it's now defended by the
knight here on B 1 the problem is Bishop
to b4 ruins all of those plans now
there's a lot of different ways that
white could continue here the worst one
would be something like Queen to d2 then
you can see
bishop take here on c3 white thinking
that he can take here on c3 because his
knights defending it but then Queen to
c1 and that's going to be checkmate now
why doesn't have to continue exactly
like that even in this position if we
see the bishop take we could see the
knight take here on c3 but then the
Queen takes on a1 the Knights forced to
come back here to d1 o most don't want
to come back to b1 and just give up more
material but now Knight takes on e5
attacking this Knight right here if the
night takes shirt the Queen's gonna come
back here black is just up a rook as
well as a pawn this is gonna be a pretty
easy game for black if white try
something else from here maybe pawn to
e3
okay Knight takes on f3 pawn takes and
then black could continue if he wants to
take material right here and doesn't
really matter if you try something else
pawn to g3 trying to fianchetto castle
on the King side it's still gonna be the
exchange here on f3 pawn takes and now
Queen to a2 none of those options are
good at all for white even if we come
back a few moves instead of the Queen
coming here to d2 maybe white just
decides immediately to take this Bishop
here on b4 ok well now the knight can
take here on b4 still attacking this
rook here on a1 so how does white really
continue here the worst way would be the
Knight to c3 because then the Queen
takes here this is checked how do you
really continue night here that's tricky
because night to see to check also for
King the rook over there on a1 but if he
doesn't play Queen to d2
okay well now Queen takes on a1 check
that's just giving up material right
here so the knight can't really come
here doesn't want to come outside
because he doesn't want to just rook to
fall here but if he just comes to a3 the
queen is going to capture it right here
so that's not going to be a very good
option either really the move that white
needs to be thinking about in this
position is Knight to c3 yes it's not
immediately attacking the
but white is in a good position here and
can attack this very soon with rook to
be one there's not a lot of great
squares that black can even go to you
may even want to continue to push with
his Bishop here to be four from here why
can just play rook to be one attacking
the Queen whereas the Queen goat really
has to go to a3 and then Knight to d5
attacking the bishop a few options that
black has maybe he just wants to take
with his Bishop on d2 we have an
exchange right here well now black has
to deal with this Knight coming to c7 so
maybe King to d8 to stop this then Queen
to g5 putting a lot of pressure one it's
checked but two it's also it's hacking
the pawn here on g7 can start to gobble
up some material right here so all know
white has a very strong attack maybe
instead we see black choose a different
option instead of taking the bishop
right here could come back to a5 from
here rook to b5 attacking the bishop now
the bishop could still come to d2 as we
talked about we have a similar situation
as before if he tries to do something
tricky may think that he could just come
back here to b6 and it safe but it's
really not because the route could just
take here that's fine because doesn't
matter how black now takes maybe the
pawn takes here Knight down to c7 check
and that is forc the rooks is gonna fall
here on a8 same thing if the pawn takes
here is gonna gobble up a pawn and he's
gonna eventually gobble up this rook
here on a why it's gonna be completely
fine here and then he can continue
develop castle on the King side if he
wants to white should be fine here so
really the key here white played all the
right moves but really when it comes
here I'm gonna need to play the Knight
to c3 so in your own games if you start
out with d4 and your opponent plays the
England game at pawn to e5 don't panic
play the normal moves you would expect
but if they do come down take on b2
don't be alarmed play Knight to c3
hopefully you guys enjoy the England
game of trap
let me know if you would like to see a
dedicated video on the game it or if you
just want to see other trap videos
thanks again for watching I'll see you
guys in the next